[Musique]
rené lévesque aurait eu 100 ans cet été
il est né le 24 août
1922 à campbellton au nouveau-brunswick
a grandi en gaspésie après ben hibon
connaît l'histoire ce à l'occasion des
événements entourant ce centième
anniversaire b ce qui aura commémoration
événement que j'ai rencontré lucien
bouchard
discussion donc autour de l'héritage de
rené lévesque de la souveraineté du pq
du plq ou si vous allez voir et du
pragmatisme de françois legault du
danger aussi que représentent des
oppositions trop faible entre vu que
j'ai réalisé à quelques jours au centre
ville dense et bleu
se bouchant bonjour bonjour on a rendu
un dernier hommage à guy lafleur il ya
plus de temps et beaucoup de gens ont
souligné sa sincérité
et on souligne à quel point il est
devenu important parce qu'ils étaient
respectées bien sûr il était aimé ce
genre de rôles dans notre histoire y en
a pas tant que ça rené lévesque fait
partie de ces gens là pour quoi pour
vous c'est important de participer à
cette année où on va souligné
l'importance de mossoul irak
c'est important puisque rené lévesque
est important
cette entreprise
ne nous permet pas seulement de prévoir
l'avenir elle constitue dès maintenant
une des clefs majeures du développement
aussi autonome que possible du québec
rené lévesque est un des plus grands
personnages politiques du québec c'est
tout naturellement que lucien bouchard
accepté de présider les célébrations
entourant son centième anniversaire
vous aimez les mots monsieur bouchard je
vous donner quelques maux vous allez me
dire ce que ça évoque pour vous quand on
pense à monsieur lévesque fierté
talker de
voulait faire de ce qu'il faisait il
voulait insuffler de la fierté
il savait qu'on est un peuple qui était
magané par l'histoire évidemment il
raconté sous voirie le véhicule lui
aussi
il voulait qu'on en sorte de la bonne
façon pas négativement par représailles
aux parents qu'une mais en faisant un
pas en avant pour nous élever nous mêmes
par une conscience plus claire de ce
qu'on est capable de faire je pense qui
a réussi un très grand parti
refaire un peu l'image qu'on a de nous
mène depuis oui c'est vrai mais quand il
y avait ces phrases extraordinaire 1 et
quelque chose comme un grand peuple
s'il y avait des services s'en
débrouiller il y avait vraiment le sens
des mots cette façon d'exprimer les jo
au bon moment j'ai été spontané c'est
est immédiat et c'était plein de vérités
pragmatisme
oui connaissions des limites en
politique il puni s'il savait jusqu'où
ça devient possible et que le danger
c'est de franchir la ligne
qui fait tomber dans l'échec dans le
rejet
dans le super match et de l'angoissé des
inquiétudes parce que son projet est un
projet qui était exigeant qui demande
énormément aux québécois franchir la
ligne de l'inconnu
il savait que c'était normal que dans
une vie collective on se pose la
question est est ce que roger est allé
jusqu alors il avait dit lui-même dans
le goulag j'ai pas le goulag j'ai pas le
goulag
canada pour nous les québécois mais ça
aussi ça manque de dire ça il n'y a pas
beaucoup de politiciens qui sont
capables de faire une conviction comme
jours avant de partir si mort et
justement si maury il était pas timoré
il y avait du courage mais en même temps
il a été prudent mais il était surtout
conscient qu'on peut pas en demander
trop aux gens on ne va jamais voulu
occuper quoi d'avoir voté non au
référendum jusqu'à un certain point il
partageait également leurs inquiétudes à
la présidence
deux députés de montréal ne riez et les
deux retraits mais sable monsieur rené
lévesque
les avants l'inquiétude il ya eu en
effet le courage le courage de changer
de route
1966 prenez les veilles qui aurait pu
rester libéral clède pour la
souveraineté association il quitte le
plq il quête des frères politique des
amis même pour aller fonder le parti
québécois
lucien bouchard à l'été 90 quétu est
aussi son ami brian mulroney pour fonder
le bloc québécois il comprend mieux que
la plupart des gens le prix à payer pour
écouter ses convictions touche à quelle
qualité ça prend on se remet dans le
contexte 1966 seul évêque sort de l'idée
dominante sort des sentiers battus et
créer quelque chose quelle qualité ça
prend pour être capable de sortir de la
pensée dominante
ça prend un sens incroyable
de l'importance du sens chrétien plus de
la liberté personnelle il l'avait au
maximum et un courage rompre avec son
milieu rempl avec les combats
avaient plein d'amis la partie divers il
a fait des choses formidables à son
devancier génial au pouvoir
le parcours des réussites du parti
libéral tout court parce que le parti
libéral d'un grand parti qui a déçu un
grand patrimoine aux québécois pour hp
avec l'oiseau remonté par ce sera une
vraie alternative à l'avenir mais la bac
avait vécu six années dans un étang sous
la révolution tranquille de québec
moderne et puis j'avais de ses amis ses
compagnons les virait la joie qu'il y
avait de l'électricité
puis
mettre de l'ordre dans les moeurs
électorales le sens de luthier que cette
extraordinaire réussite de ceux ci
génère alors rompre avec cette équipe
avec les amis ce sera plus ça tu prends
un courage énorme et a dû être emmené
les rues d'ailleurs il ya eu de vivre
très mal heureusement rompent avec des
amis vont avec des vins qui nous sont
chères cdu c'est peut-être la pire chose
qu'on soit appelé à faire un jour un
policier que si jamais on pense qu'on
peut pas continuer et donc été logique
parce qu'il ya vu que je ne fais pas
continuer donc ça prend la lucidité mais
après ça prend tout un courage pour
aller au bout de diagnostic qu'on a posé
vous parler de rupture
évidemment la vôtre avec monsieur
mulroney c'est dans cet ordre là est ce
que c'est une blessure que vous avez
encore brillamment
sûrement le seul il faut dire que c'est
pas nécessaire aux policiers qu on en
arrive là mais les enjeux était telle
dans ces périodes de la vie politique
au québec et au canada que à montmagny
est exposé à un moment il y avait des
choix pouvant table affaire qui le
d'être achevé qu'une seule barre à peu
près jamais bon mais je me vois des mois
un entretien il rapporte yves et on se
parle on peut se parler au téléphone on
se rencontre
on discute des choses qui nous
rapprochent qu'on parle surtout nous a
en particulier parce que c'est vrai on
nous connaît ses enfants et canadiens et
tous puis et puis mes enfants mais avoir
beaucoup monsieur majorité puis moi le
matin bien que les enfants aussi
mais il ya cette blessure dont on ne
parle pas on par la population ont alors
dû choses qui nous rapprochent que ce
qu'il dit c'est pas sur votre liste ou
se bouche à d'essayer de
1 sous peu je sais pas où quand comment
peut-elle y a les cheveux il ya
plusieurs motos mais le rêve à dire le
choper les réconciliations ouais ça
devient salée veut
édifier mais vous savez on n'est pas le
seul à avoir vécu cela parce que voilà
monsieur parizeau monsieur ben moi j'ai
toujours senti que monsieur parizeau
j'ai la pauvre regretter mais avait un
conseil de blessure d'avoir rompu aux
vins de la vallée
rupture trahison la politique est un
opéra parfois merveilleux parfois d'une
grande cruauté
1984 rené lévesque est brisé il ya eu ce
coup sur coup le rapatriement unilatéral
où il perd la partie devant trudeau et
ensuite un affrontement douloureux avec
les syndicats de la fonction publique
arrive à ottawa fraîchement élu brian
mulroney avec son oeuvre de réintégrer
le québec dans la constitution aura face
à nous du prochain gouvernement
conservateur nous allons espérons le et
de bonne foi converse l'assemblée
nationale du québec de donner son
assentiment à la nouvelle constitution
canadienne avec honneur et enthousiasme
le fameux discours de sept îles écrit
par lucien bouchard
rené lévesque accepte qu'il appellera le
beau risque du fédéralisme renouvelé
résultat c'est la brisure le départ de
cinq ministres dont camille laurens et
jacques parizeau qui n'acceptent pas que
l'éveil tourner le dos à la souveraineté
le beau risque le brevet et
monsieur par utah me chercher des
solutions à ce qu'on pourrait le penser
et ça aura la chance mais avec toujours
compliqué les relations complexes
d'admiration de respect
deux grands personnages ensemble dans la
même équipe qui ont vraiment donné se
sont séparés en ma critique mais je
l'avais quand même souffert beaucoup
énormément et monsieur bayrou m'a déjà
donné entend lui aussi qui y comprenez
ce qu'on est ce qu'on éprouve de
de peine à voir durant pavec parce que
vous savez dans la vie on ne reconstruit
pas d amitié comme j'aurais surtout les
amitiés de jeunesse et où il paie des
métiers qui deviennent presque
fraternelle et de les rendre
évidemment
il ça peut pas se ressouder vraiment
parce que c'était dur
en 1980 rené lévesque accepte la défaite
si j'osais bien compris vous êtes en
train de dire à la prochaine fois
mais certains au pq aurait voulu qu'il
poursuive la quête du grand jour plutôt
que de tenter le beau risque même chose
pour lucien bouchard après les résultats
serrés de 95 des péquistes souhaitait un
match revanche rapide
le pur et dur lui ont reproché à
monsieur lévesque d'aller dans cette
voie là de s'engager dans cette voie là
vous il ya des gens qui auraient voulu
au lendemain du référendum de 95 que
vous fassiez un ut un autre match
revanche on vous a reproché sa pub et
allaient plutôt dans des bus et tramways
dans peur de leur projet avec la peur
d'un troisième référendum j'ai convaincu
aujourd'hui ben oui bien sûr et était
d'une dire irresponsabilité fondamentale
de s'exposer un troisième échec on
serait rassurée confiante ou du plancher
après franchement on peut pas faire de
référendum au québec puis-je pour ça que
personne n'y pense aujourd'hui ça avoir
un minimum de certitudes d'un homme
raisonnable que on a des bonnes chances
de gagner j'étais pas le cas après après
ce référendum ne s'était pas confier le
parti et à appuyer le parti québécois
était épuisé les ressources je n'avais
plus les jeunes demandez pas de
référendum à ce moment là les gens
voulaient jeu de mode est un peu comment
on va sortir la démission de monsieur
parizeau ou l'échec des 95 et ainsi de
suite il fallait rebâtir un minimum de
confiance faudra bâtir autour de l'état
québécois autour de l'intégrité des
finances publiques qui était très menacé
à l'époque vous comprenez bien l'état
dans lequel il se trouvait quand après
yad j'allais chercher 700 millions dans
la poche du travailleur québécois vous
vous dites oui à l'idéal de la
souveraineté les purs et durs nous
disent ceci mais ya la réalité aussi qui
nous rattrape
je crois les appuis fondamentaux du
parti québécois souhaitaient le maintien
dicale ça commençait la tête il a pu
presque inconditionnelle
et le grave le coup le plus grave qui a
été porté au monde syndical si cette
décision de rené la veille de son
gouvernement
de diminuer les salaires de la fonction
publique jusqu'à 20% pendant une période
de temps et ensuite de les remettre un
niveau qui soit celui
le pas sage et puis par une noire par la
volonté par l'autorité de l'état brut et
brutal de l'état rené lévesque
importance a été le cas encore une fois
il s'est comporté comme un homme
réaliste et responsable
oui ce serait terrible pour la suite des
choses quant aux rapports entre le parti
québécois est chez j'appuie
traditionnels je te prenant le syndical
non plus rêver il y avait comme si un
préjugé prochain tikal très accentuées
mais j'étais l'intégrité de l'état
québécois on était quand on était sur le
point d'être des côtés et on pouvait pas
respecté les engagements qui avaient été
pris dans les conventions collectives
qui comportait une indexation totale et
l'inflation monte à 14% alors là il faut
les surveiller et à sauver d'état ce qui
est plus important chez nous donc il ya
auger venu chez déchiré j'ai déchiré le
kent et je l'étais déjà une carrière
politique demande élevée c'est une
souche est une suite de montagnes russes
d'exaltation la victoire de sa déjà est
bien celui des grandes réussites à son
gouvernement mais en même temps des
échecs qui lui laisse des traces dans la
constitution dans nos pouvoirs colicci
est situé est-ce que son véhicule qu'il
a créé
vous êtes d'avis qu'il est en effet sur
le bord de la base du parti québécois
lors du party pas l'idée de la suivante
je pense que monsieur lévesque a
toujours fait la distinction entre son
objectif était la souveraineté du québec
restauration d'un pays aux yeux de
l'état du québec et le véhicule pour y
arriver bien voulu faire au sein du
parti libéral safran a fait bon je ne
voulais pas aller jusque là à là il
s'est créé un véhicule à lui mais je
n'ai pas un homme de parti et les
vallées sap a eu beau faire partie
que lui
quand on est un parti fort dans la
partie et fo le flatter votre l'apchq
ça prend tout un tempérament la chanaye
ce n'est pas mon tempérament mystère
policiers encore moins avec la chaleur
est ce qu'on va assister monsieur
bouchard là bientôt à la mort de ce
véhicule
ben ce véhicule se
véhiculer du g8 les gens n'en veulent
plus bas on ne croisera un autre qui est
important
c'est le rêve qui l'animait ça ça meurt
pas rêve le rêve est aujourd'hui ses
portes comment ce rêve là souvent pas
pour le moment et
pour le moment est un peu tamisée
il est d'accord je pense très fort mais
de penser le traduire en une réalité à
travers les activités d'un parti d'un
référendum on n'est pas là on n'est pas
là on n'est plus là ou non on sera leur
jour puis connaît l'avenir
qu'est-ce qui peut l'amener sur les
rives de n'importe quoi qui arrivent de
tous les possibles à mener alors oui un
projet souverainiste qui a animé toute
une génération qui nous a fait faire des
choses très correct dans l'intégrité
dans l'honneur dans le respect des
individus la démocratie aussi bas qu'en
95% des gens à voter un référendum comme
en 95 kg a pas un incident de violence
ça prend tout un peuple démocratique
pour réussir une chose comme ça là oui
mais l'idée le projet
c'est un rêve
c'était également je pense une nécessité
politique quand on regarde l'histoire du
québec on peut pas se laisser dépouiller
comme moi cherche présentement soit
acculé dans le coin langue française je
me lâche et non il faut garder l'idée il
faut garder la détermination mais comme
un show on ne sait pas quelle forme ça
va prendre ce qu elles savent
transformer comment
peut-être ou peut-être pas un
professionnel chez paraty riches comme
on dit avec j'avais je me suis certain
qu'il ya quelque chose qui me l'ait
mohawk rapport et qui va s'exprimer
d'une façon que gino dans la vie
politique québécoise
donc moi je me vois désespéré à l'idée
que le parti québécois bien
même s'il ne sera que nous ayons fait
entre nous il m'invite pas très bien non
plus oui papa samba c'est ce beau monde
y en a des gens que je pense que j'ai
beaucoup de respect puis ci ayant du
mérite mais disons que les quelque chose
qui ne clique pas de là dans le débat
politique il ya quelque chose comme un
supplice ou si on a mal pour d'ici noël
tant qu'ils restent là bas on peut
imaginer que peut-on imaginer que un
parti
2022 en octobre offert une campagne
électorale où il va promettre un
référendum qui était
pour vous c'est de la folie pour la
folie mais c'est un manque de défaut
avec n'avait pas
est-ce que ce legault en terminant
monsieur bouchard a trouvé finalement la
formule de faire une coalition et de
tenter
d'exploiter ou de faire naître nationale
et sous un peu plus revendicateurs même
si on voit pas beaucoup d'effet dans les
relations fédérales provinciales mais on
le voit est un taux d'approbation qui
presque dangereux
un parler de quatre parties monsieur
legault jeux légaux oui
est ce qu'il n'ya pas de trouver la
formule gagnante de national et sans
rupture dans leur choix de god eater
biya liste
françois legault le françois legault que
je connais et que j'ai vu dans l'action
mais que je connais par des relations
personnelles et amicales c'est un
réaliste qui fait une bonne lecture il
fait une lecture d'associations
politiques en politique faut savoir dire
moi je connais
gardons la carte le pays va chauffer le
banc va lui sait où on est il ya une
bonne lecture de la population
actuellement
et on peut pas lui reprocher aux il en
profite que beaucoup de gens partagent
son opinion
c'est la réalité
actuellement on peut penser que
si la tendance se maintient comme vous
disiez radio canada on peut penser que
ça va être une élection de maréchal
comme on dit
mais qu'est ce qu'on peut lui reprocher
parce que s'il est ce que la population
veut mais est ce qu'il n'ya pas danger
qui que l'eau polisot position au québec
soit tellement faible
oui c'est pas bon je vais vous pouvez
vous dire
comme je suis bon en politique que je
peux dire parce que tout reste que
touchent pas moi vous pouvez jeunes un
peu malheureux de voir ce qui arrive au
parti libéral puis pas bon ça après les
mots crassier québécois j'ai pas grave
aux élections qui va venir
résultat pour un voyant de fait mais
c'est pas grave mais dans l'avenir il
faut que je parte il se reconstitue et
on dirait que les gens oublient ou parce
que vous pouvez très amicalement mort il
a mis la partie mais on dirait qu'ils
ont oublié ce que c'est que leur parti
leur parti est une coalition de
francophones nationaliste mais
fédéraliste et avec les anglophones et
les communautés c'est une coalition donc
ça prend d'après un orfèvre pour virer
une coalition il avait avec robert
bourassa il aurait eu avec mario dumont
par houston en fait du même genre mais
parti libéral va devoir se reconstituer
pas essayé bien là faut plaire une
journée lendemain faut plaire un
plan d'ensemble
il faut se rappeler ce qu'a été le parti
du père en fils doit être encore c'est
un grand parti le parti libéral et
l'histoire du québec depuis 50 ans
partout vous avez dit intervention
extraordinaire du parti libéral un grand
patrimoine dont elles parties peuvent
être fiers mais faut pas qu'ils oublient
sapho qui reconstituent et tout ça il
faut qu'ils se rappellent qu'ils sont
tous qui se rappelle que les québécois
même fédéraliste îles francophones
québécois même fédérale et même
fédéralistes sont nationales et
il ya beaucoup de fièvre du parti
libéral qui l'ont oublié vous dites
c'est un c'est un élément essentiel dans
la dynamique politique mais c'est comme
si déjà où je compte y est la
disparition du pq dans votre analyse
c'est le comptage
j'ai pas que disparaît
voit qu il faut qu'il retire son projet
s'il veut durer qui veut être pertinents
c'est un parti qui doit refaire son
projet fou quel courage de faire partir
quelqu'un à juin n'a été capable de
faire des châteaux chiche analyse en
profondeur pour se remettre en question
j'invite alors c'était pareil je pas été
capable non plus puis monsieur lévesque
avait un véhicule même problème dont
souffrent eux aussi chaud que monsieur
parizeau il leur disait pas mal ce
qu'ils voulaient à temps mais on devait
ou chasse à l'homme menée
lucien bouchard a été tenté de faire
naître une troisième voix nationalistes
mais sans projet de référendum il a
plutôt choisi sa famille ses deux fils
et s'il ne sait pas comment le projet
souverainiste évoluera quelle forme tout
ça prendra et même si ça arrivera il
sait par contre que pour qu'aboutisse
des rêves il faut des lieder qui inspire
si on veut réanimer la vie policiers
j'ai envie retrouver les bases d'une
réunion publique des jus lente active
amener les jeunes à entrer en politique
est inquiet parce que les vins ne sont
pas là vous savez actuellement il faut
qu'il revienne faut que sois présent il
faut qu'il reconstitue
le personnel politique québécois info
qu'il refasse le leadership ben il faut
que je t'aurais de mémoire de vendée
lévesque pour rappeler qu'ils étaient là
pour rappeler qui peut nous inspirer à
beaucoup d'égards et que c'est quelqu'un
qui donne une vie qualifié puis
heureusement il y ait dans la taille de
tout le monde si on parle de premier
ministre la référence sur un élevage
on veut le rappeler à tout le monde je
sais bouchard merci beaucoup merci pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit